I just got done watching the WWDC
virtual keynotes
it was absolutely amazing now I say this
because the past few years I've actually
got a chance to go to WWE and be there
and witness it in person now this
definitely wasn't and replacement for
being there in person but what I think
they did with this keynote is they made
it feel like everyone was actually there
so actually having been to Apple Park
and getting to see all these really cool
places it felt a lot more inclusive it
felt like you guys were actually getting
to experience what we experienced there
in person so Apple amazing job in the
keynote I really enjoyed it and I hope
that you guys did too now let's do a
quick recap of everything that they
talked about in the keynote are you
ready I think I am alright let's get
into it first up we have iOS 14 one of
the most exciting things about WTC
you've seen widgets before but now you
can take those widgets and completely
integrate them into your homescreen this
does have a very Android feel I know as
soon as I tweeted this everyone's like
welcome to Android yeah but see here's
the thing okay maybe you're right
but I'm so excited about it they called
this a smart stack the widgets are
intelligently curated based on the apps
you use the most and the right widget
will show up automatically at the right
time of your day this is the only app
library so it'll automatically organize
all of your apps into one simple easy to
navigate view I can't believe that it's
taken them this long to do this I
searched for everything so I swipe down
and I search for the app that I'm
looking for so the new app library view
looks pretty cool you guys know when you
get a phone call or a FaceTime and it
completely takes over your entire home
screen well now they have contact calls
so it calls from your phone FaceTime or
third-party apps little splay in an
all-new compact design that doesn't take
up a full screen way way overdue
fix your in picture is a huge update
that I think is gonna be really helpful
for all of us who like to watch a lot of
content and also try to get work done at
the same time so you can still watch
your content while you're doing other
things on your phone there's been a lot
of updates to messages this is something
that I think a lot of people have been
waiting for
pinned conversations you can pin up to
nine of your most important
conversations to the
of your conversation list so you can
easily get to them and if these are
group chats I've got little pop-up
notifications on these groups to see who
replied the latest so this kind of gives
you a really quick look at what the
conversations are actually happening
without having to click in mentions is
also really exciting because a lot of
times you'll be in a group chat and
you'll kind of want to be conversing
with everybody would also direct that
message to someone specific I feel like
at one point you've probably been
overwhelmed in group messages and need
to reply to a specific topic but that
topic has long gone they have inline
replies so you can apply directly to a
specific message in a group conversation
or their own thread for more focus views
you can click into it and see that
entire thread of the inline conversation
to make it so much easier to be able to
have conversations inside of a group
text it gets hectic there's new emoji
styles and stickers you can get a new
age option you can choose from 20 new
hair and headwear styles to reflect your
hobby profession and personality they
now have an emoji with a face mask I
think this is amazing and I think if you
have a face mask you should wear it
there's really no reason you should it
just just wear the mask I can't wait to
put an emoji mask on my face we also
have a new update to maps they have
cycling directions so you can use maps
to get directions using bike lanes paths
roads you can also see the elevation if
streets are busy and if there's stairs
which i think is very important
especially if you're riding a bike it'll
give you the option to skip the stairs
or to show you where the stairs are
where you'll need to walk your bike up
then they even have an electric vehicle
routing I know easy is the way of the
future so being able to have this and
have your route planned according to
where you can charge your car is very
important even a lot of cars already
have that integrated the fact that this
is something that is in Apple maps now
is pretty cool those new translate apps
you'll be able to have conversations
with people with other languages you can
tap the single microphone button in the
center here and it will allow you to
have a conversation and translate back
and forth between the languages Siri our
dear friend Siri who works I'm not sure
what the percentages but we'll just
leave it at that it has a new compact
design which I really like so it'll show
you when Siri is activate at the bottom
and then instead of entire
taking over your whole screen much like
the FaceTime calls you'll get these
little notifications up at the top where
Siri is answering or giving you grocery
lists they showed a demo of this BMW car
that you're able to unlock using NFC on
your phone and then you're able to set
different keys for other people so if
Jenna wants to drive my car and I want
to maybe limit her restrictions as far
as what she can do and where she can go
I can assign her a key and then she can
use her phone to unlock and start the
car and I think I need to get one of
these BMWs to review I'm just like I
think it's just we need this there's a
new update to carplay so you can change
the wallpapers and different app types
which I'm kind of excited about this
because I use carplay
all the time when I'm driving which
hasn't been much lately because I I've
been stuck in the house several months
but when I do start driving I look
forward to changing the wallpaper on my
car play air pods are also getting an
update you'll be able to use spatial
audio so it's using surround sound but
it's using the motion of the air pod to
detect like where your head is in the
space of where this surround sound
should be this is cool too so there's
audio sharing for Apple TV so you can
connect two sets of ear pods to your
Apple TV 4k so you can enjoy movies and
Scholz with your friends well one friend
and not have to use the speakers on your
TV app clips is also something that's
interesting so a lot of times you'll be
presented at a place like a coffee shop
or trying to run a bike or something and
you won't have the app that you need to
use this item so it's basically like a
little NFC so you can click it and it
will quickly pop up a notification and
you can access whatever it is that you
need to access from that app without
downloading the entire app there's a new
privacy update as well and I was 14 so
it's giving you more control over the
data that you share and more
transparency into how it's used I loved
using signing with Apple they're gonna
be giving you the option to update some
of your old accounts and synchronize
them with sign-in with Apple to be able
to have that privacy that comes along
with that ok what else did they talk
about there's so much stuff that
happened in this keynote I'm overwhelmed
they're also a bunch of new iPad OS
updates some of them carry over from the
iOS 14 but one of the things that I was
most excited about was scribble this is
an update to the Apple pencil and iPad
OS integration this is really cool so
you'll actually ever have to put your
Apple pencil away because you
right by hand in any text field across
iPad OS and the words will automatically
convert to text so you can vert your
handwriting automatically in any type of
text field and it'll convert it to text
this is so cool to look at this they
have a scratch to delete so if you make
a mistake you can just scratch out the
text and it will delete it there's so
many cool things that they decided to
integrate with this like shape
recognition you can automatically turn a
roughly put your hung star into this
beautiful masterpiece the only give any
of you guys have ever used procreate or
any type of drawing tools something like
this is fairly common so the fact that
they're integrating this right into
notes is really cool there's built-in
data detectors so it'll recognize
addresses phone numbers email addresses
and other data that has handwritten in
text and you can tap them to take action
so overall they've done some cosmetic
updates kind of pulling from that whole
iOS 14 world and just transferring it
over to the iPad OS you'll see that a
lot of the experiences have been
redesigned and streamlined also has the
redesigned widgets new app design new
search and of course the compact calls
scribble hyped about scribble I can't
wait to try out the new iOS 14 Anthony
why iPad OS I actually have them
downloading on my phone and on my
previous gen iPad right now so look for
a video coming up covering all of those
a little more in-depth but now moving on
to Mac OS which they are calling big sur
Mac OS Big Sur you know what that means
I mean there was more take in a road
trip we went to Catalina for the launch
of Catalina last year or two years one
of her oh my gosh the time is flying
it was interesting while I was watching
them do the demos and talk about
everything because it really felt like
it's a more robust version of iOS and I
think that's kind of what they're trying
to do is make everything feel very
seamless like you're going from your
iPad to your math back to your iPhone
and everything kind of feels like it's
all in the same ecosystem they've got
all new streamlined apps from
full-height sidebars to refresh toolbars
a clean you app design they've also got
a refresh doc it's a sleek design and
this update makes getting to your
favorite apps even easier they have a
new uniform shape for app icons which
adds consistency while letting the
personality of Mac shine through so I
never really thought about it before but
look at all of these app
I have my doc right now you can tell
that they have sort of their own shape
so they're kind of bringing everything
to be a more uniform to look and you
know what that look is looks a lot like
iOS these look just like the apps that
you would click on your phone or your
iPad here's the new control center for
Mac so you can instantly access all the
controls that you can use the most like
Wi-Fi or Bluetooth and all of these
controls you can use to play music and
evil dark mode for your display the new
control center will also let you drag
your favorites to the menu so you can
customise it much like you do on on what
now oh that's right your phone like the
control center on your phone like in iOS
it's an all-new Safari
they've got some updates there which is
very exciting you can customize that
start page there's Safari extensions in
the App Store so if you do have an
extension that you've used previously
they now have a dedicated section in the
App Store for Safari extensions they
also have an approved tab design so if
you are someone who uses tabs which I
definitely do they have a new look so
this means that you could have more tabs
visible at the same time you can also
hover over one of the tabs and this will
bring up an instant image of what that
website is do you have to be able to see
what that tab is without having to
actually click into it before you could
only make your me emoji on your phone or
your iPad but now you can also make them
on your Mac the new redesigned Apple
apps will also be integrated into Mac OS
so you'll be able to take advantage of
those and also the new guides will allow
you to discover new places to eat shop
and explore with curated guides from
brands you love I think I want to curate
a guide since I used to travel a lot
there's so many amazing places that I've
found on my travels that maybe I can I
want to make a guide I can't look it
says you can create your own guide for
your favorite places and show them with
your friends and family you guys are my
friends some of you are my family
one of the biggest rumors is Apple
transitioning away from Intel chips and
acceptability making this transition
over the course of the next two years
with the first Mac shipping with our new
Apple chip by the end of this year today
is the day we're announcing that the Mac
is transitioning
to our own Apple silica and the fact
that they're gonna be making this
transition over the next two years is a
pretty quick turnover you guys remember
Apple used to be using the PowerPC chips
they then went to Intel and now many
years later they're deciding to take
this all in-house and create their own
chips themselves and at one point in the
keynote Craig was like hey I have a
confession to make this isn't the first
time you've seen Mac OS running here in
fact this is the same Mac that Beth and
I used to demo all the new Big Sur
features earlier so now I'll go making
these chips in-house this will allow
them to increase the performance
increase battery life and really be able
to fine tune all of the things that they
were not able to do before because they
weren't actually making these chips
they'll be able to make them exactly how
they need them and have them do exactly
what they need to do WWDC is a
Developers Conference and what's really
cool is today developers would be able
to apply for a Mac Mini so they can
start preparing their apps for the new
custom chip that Apple is creating so
this is really gonna be exciting for
them because they're gonna be able to
get this thing firsthand
start developing for it and preparing
all the apps for this big change that is
coming up I mean I remember I was kind
of young I guess let me see when it was
how old was I when they switched this
over let's see June 6 2005 ok so I guess
I wasn't about you I guess in my mind it
felt like I was like 4 but I guess I
wasn't so it's actually right before I
started my YouTube channel and I do
remember what a huge deal this was so
now kind of reflecting on that it's
pretty incredible that now Apple is
taking this all in-house last but not
least I'm surprised I didn't talk about
this first but it's the last thing that
they have featured on their website
watch OS 7 okay first of all we need to
talk about this there's a new hand
washing app is it an app but it says
that it can detect the sound of water
and the squishing of the soap and it'll
activate the hand washing feature it
will let you know if you're washing your
hands long enough I hope this is
something that I can share like I would
start an entire Twitter account for just
team washing your hands so I watch with
Auto to eat every time I was that's
weird but I would do it there's a bunch
of new watch faces could also share
these watch faces which is kind of cool
they're calling it face sharing so if
somebody sees the watch face that I have
right now they're like wow I really like
that I could just press and hold and
share it to them you can also create
faces in the app store so if I want to
create a face and have it shared for the
world I guess I can do that as well they
now have a new sleep app which is cool
but if I sleep with my watch on when
will I charge it you can get a sleep
chart you can have your sleep tracking
so it uses the accelerometer to notice
the subtle movements associated with
breathing and it will differentiate
between sleeping and waking States
fitness they added a new dance activity
so I love tracking my fitness on my
Apple watch
I mean I've this since day one that
they've integrated the fitness tracking
in here I feel like I've become a much
healthier person because of it now you
can have a dance workout it's a
full-body workout that's good for your
heart makes you stronger and improves
coordination so dance like nobody's
watching and get credit for it on your
watch that's cool they're changing the
activity app to be called the fitness
app which I think it's kind of an
interesting move because I know there
are a bunch of rumors of apples starting
their own sort of fitness classes and
fitness videos so this would kind of be
setting them up to rule those things out
potentially in the future which I think
would be really cool there is so much
that Apple covered at WWDC and even just
looking at their website and going in
and reading some of the notes further
there's a lot of stuff that they didn't
even talk about in the keynote so I look
forward to covering some more of this
very extensively and as I said I am
downloading iOS 14 and the new iPad OS
right now and I'm most excited to test
out scribble I'm gonna make a whole
scribble video I have to I can't wait if
there's anything that you would like me
to make a video about more in depth make
sure you guys leave those in the
comments below and I will also see you
guys the discord server
I made a WDC section there so I'll put a
link in the description if you guys
gonna check that out that's it see you
guys later
[Music]